Matt: Hi, my name is Matt.
Matt: And today I'm going to be performing the task. SGT.
Matt: Tracking your expenses with money manager number 4,
Matt: and the slug
Matt: is
Matt: UOCI.
Matt: Dash RCLL. Dash 1 1.
Matt: And for the task today I'll be using a Google Pixel 6
Matt: running the latest version of Android 14, and the latest version of Talkback.
Matt: which I believe is 14.1.
Matt: My task today, while using the app, I'm going to be creating some expense categories and adding my income. I'm going to add some expenses and transactions.
Matt: and I need to keep in mind that I cannot spend
Matt: more than my income, and I will be checking in to see
Matt: how much total that I have spent. Finally, I'm I'm going to edit one of the
Matt: Budget categories to change the name or budget and save it. Next, I'm going to create a budget plan and add a a deadline for any day next month. And lastly, I'm going to check out the 2 analysis results.
Matt: So let's get started. Shall we? First, I'm going to
Matt: create
Matt: an expense category
Matt: and add an income. So I'm going to create about 2
Matt: 2 categories. For this example, I'm going to create a food cat groceries, category and a
Matt: entertainment or recreation category.
Matt: So what I'm going to do is I'm going to be using a mixture of braille for typing, as it's my preferred method as well as swiping with my
Matt: fingers on the phone. But I'll be giving instructions as I navigate along. I'll generally be using a lot of left and right swiping as well as double tapping
Matt: to make selections. So I am at the main screen.
Matt: I'm just going to jump over to the app
Matt: now. So at the moment open navigation join
Matt: talkback announces open navigation drawer
Matt: month's expenses, and I'm just swiping to the right. It says, month, month expenses, more options, but we have a more options, category date.
Matt: and then it says, category, name your expenses this month. Your expenses. This month total expenses.
Matt: total expenses add expense, button. add expense. Button. Now. from what I see here, it it doesn't appear that there's anything available to me.
Matt: Yet. It would be nice if it sort of had a
Matt: dialog that came up and said, Hey, just so, you know you. There's no expenses as of yet. So what I'm going to do. Annotation. But
Matt: add expense. Button is naturally I'm expense.
Matt: Button.
Matt: By double tapping on my screen.
Matt: add product, category, dropdown list detected icon down image animation.
Matt: money manager, total expense. At first it didn't look like it. Did anything so add expense button.
Matt: I'm going to double tap again on add expense.
Matt: and in braille it's a transaction on a category. Ok. In braille. I was going to state, it says, add new transaction. But talkback did not immediately speak.
Matt: It actually took a few seconds for it to
Matt: start speaking. Which made me think it didn't do anything.
Matt: So we're now in the product category
Matt: detected. IC product category. And I don't know if this is an element I can interact with. So this is a dropdown. So I'm going to
Matt: guess that this is something I can interact with. So I'm going to
Matt: and activate it now.
Matt: which I've now done. But there's no speech, and there's no either input on the braille display. Enter info any box.
Matt: Okay? So doesn't look like I can interact with this drop down. It's sort of misleading here. Product category.
Matt: So enter info in a box is this, enter info characters, enter 0 10
Matt: 0 of 10 characters. Answer. Info in a box
Matt: transaction. Thank you.
Matt: 2,024. Okay, trans. Enter characters enter, enter info
Matt: detected icon. So before I get
Matt: any further, I'm going to try once more to activate this dropdown. And it looks like I can't.
Matt: December fourteenth in a box. I guess I'll have to just detect it.
Matt: I apologize for the pause there. I just needed some clarification as to where I was. So it actually looks like this was a transaction screen
Matt: and so ignore. But
Matt: I apologize, Buddy Badger.
Matt: So it actually looks like I am
Matt: not in the right spot. It looks like when you hit add expense. I was adding a transaction which was very misleading, so I'm going to examine the navigation drawer, and I'm going to double, tap and activate it here.
Matt: Money manager, manage your budget, track your expenses and control your plans.
Matt: Okay? So it says, money manager, manage your budget. track your expenses and control your plans.
Matt: and I'm going to swipe to the right month's expenses checked.
Matt: So looks like. These are a check box that says monthly expenses is checked. Budget categories.
Matt: We have budget categories, budget analysis. budget analysis, monthly expenses, analysis. monthly expenses, analysis, budget plans.
Matt: budget plans, annotation button. And then that is it. So? I'm going to assume that the budget categories
Matt: is the correct spot
Matt: budget analysis, budget categories.
Matt: It would be a nice if it is, in fact, the correct option.
Matt: if it would be labeled as the
Matt: expense categories. If this is in fact, the correct option. So I'm gonna hit
Matt: the checkbox here. Double tap, check open navigation door
Matt: talkback says, checked, and immediately drops me into this
Matt: screen again budget categories. And now it's changed from
Matt: monthly expenses to budget categories.
Matt: Category name gotcha
Fab
Matt: detected icon add annotation button detected. Icon add add budget. But it's actually unlabeled. Category name. So let's double tap on category name. First, let's do more options.
Matt: Pop-up window your wallet. Add income
Matt: settings, okay, add income. So let's add the oops. Let's add the income. First. Add to your wallet add income, button
Matt: money, amount, 80 bucks
Matt: annotation.
Matt: I'm going to say Mike.
Matt: come is
Matt: let's use 25
Matt: 100 a month and click done. 1,500 keyboard hidden keyboard is now hidden, and in this edit box should be
Matt: money manager, roller options.
Matt: budget. and I got out of the accident. There. I'm just going to add in them.
Matt: Add to your wallet, add income.
Matt: Try that again. Money manager, more options.
Matt: pop-up window your wallet.
Matt: add income, add to your wallet.
Matt: stop, share button.
Matt: add in my amount in a box.
Matt: Okay, so let's try this one more time
Matt: showing Braille keyboard. English comma.
Matt: Actually, we're gonna type in 2,500 again.
0.
Matt: And that's done. I'm going to hit done on my display. 2,500 keyboard hidden. Ok, I got the confirmation from talkback.
Matt: And now I'm going to activate the Add income button.
Matt: Your wallet contains now 2,500.0 money manager. More options.
Matt: Excellent! Excellent. I love when things let you know that you have successfully added, especially for money apps like this. So great work with that nice to have that announcement.
Matt: And now that our income is added, we're going to add the 2 categories. So I said before, we're going to add an entertainment category and a groceries category.
Matt: So I'm going to find that category name.
Matt: and I want to see if I can just hit the category name here.
Matt: and it doesn't appear to do anything. Budget. So let's add, detected icon add image icon on a green background. Description, accuracy, medium. So this is. This is an unlabeled button. Talkback does identify it. However, in Braille it does not have any label. It just says unlabeled button. So it's important to remember to label buttons so that everyone knows what is, in fact, going on
Matt: So if I double tap this, I can add.
and
Matt: a category. So it's at our first category, which would be groceries.
Matt: budget, category info category name data box category name. So we're gonna type in for this one. We're gonna type in groceries
Matt: showing braille, keyboard. English braille, United States bear expedition. Okay, I'll type in groceries.
Dot say, GROC, ERIE, S.
Matt: Okay, and I'm going to navigate
Matt: and activate the next button growth budget. Write the maximum amount of money you can spend in this category edit box editing.
Matt: Okay? Submitting text oops, keyboard hidden.
Matt: I need to apologize there.
Matt: Budget right? The maximum amount of money you can spend in this category data box. Okay, I'm gonna activate the set of box here showing Braille keyboard, English braille, United States American edition.
Matt: and I'm going to say. For groceries that I can spend $350 a month. So I'll type in
Matt: 3, 5, 0 3, 5 0 and click done
Matt: so. 350 keyboard hidden.
Matt: Alright. I'm going to swipe to the right
Matt: clear text. Write the maximum amount of money you can spend in this category.
Matt: Okay, there's data
Matt: prompt there, add income
Matt: adaptation, add income.
Matt: Now, I thought we had added the income. But I'm hoping this will just add the category.
Matt:  So if this is, in fact, adding the categories a little misleading.
Matt: let's see what happens when I activate it.
Matt: Like add income
Matt: money manager detected icon add image icon on a green background. Description, accuracy, medium.
Matt: Okay. So nothing
Matt: spoke. But it did bring me back to the screen. $350.
Matt: Sesame's okay. And I'm just wiping to the right. Perfect. Okay?
Matt: Wonderful. So it did add. But it would be nice to get get an announcement that the category groceries was added with a
Matt: spending of, and I'm going to add one more category detected icon image
Matt: budget category and phone category. And we're connected. We're gonna call it entertainment
Matt: showing brand keyboard, English brand, United States American edition. MT.
Bye.
it's deleted.
Okay.
There you go. Semicolon tea
Matt: budget. Right? The maximum amount of money of his characters. Enter 13 of entertainment edit box. Okay. Category needed. I was just confirming my
Matt: typing. Sosa's entertainment characters enter 13 of 50.
Matt: It says, 1350 characters. Budget. Write the maximum amount of money you can spend in this category edit box editing. Okay
Matt: for entertainment, I'm going to
Matt: say.
and let's see
Matt: 2, 50, and then click done 250 keyboard hidden
Matt: clear text. Write the maximum amount. Add income.
Matt: Okay, it's it's not necessary to have the prompt here twice as talk back already has announced it. It's just extra swiping that one needs to do
Matt: So I'm going to click add income, which again would be nice that this
Matt:  would speak once I click it.
Matt: Money manager detected icon add image icon on a green background, description, accuracy, medium. So I'm back on the money manager and I'm back to the Add Button, which again is unlabeled. So I have to swipe to the left $250 entertainment.
Matt: $350, groceries, budget.
Matt: And there's my
Matt: budget category. Name Budget gross 300 entertain 200 detected icon annotation button detected. Icon. Okay, detected icon.
Matt: Why don't we actually add one more? So I'll just do this really quick. I'm going to add a third category for food. So keep that project Category
Matt: characters and Category name
Matt: showing. Okay, oops. Category name will call it food.
Matt: Next budget budget. Let's do
Matt: monthly budget of
Matt: 2 50 and click done
Matt: 250 keyboard hidden clear text. Write the maximum amount, add income
Matt: and add income swipe there. Okay, we've got some
Matt: items here.
Matt:  I'm just going to refer
Matt: back to the notes here after I've added the income and the categories.
Matt: I'm now going to add some
Matt: expenses and transactions. So what I need to do
Matt: is I need to
Matt: go back to the menu, open navigation, join at the top
Matt: budget categories and change from
Matt: budget categories, more options, cap more. Budget category open
Matt: money, manager months expenses.
Matt: 2 months expenses. We're going to give this a shot. So I'm going to double tap on month's expenses. Hold the navigation, join
Matt: month's expenses
Matt: more options, category. Name
Matt: your expenses this month questions.
Matt: budget safer, Slider, syndrome percent.
Matt: Okay, there's a side, it says.
Matt: seek scroll bar
Matt: 0. I have no idea what this is for. $0. 100 and $50.
Matt: Okay, there's a picker for dollar amount. I wonder if I can just type it in manually.
Matt: can't. So normally, what I would do?
Matt: Yeah, because this is a, so seek control
Matt: is, I can use my swipe up gesture
Matt: 5%. And it's announcing 10%, 15% percentages.
Matt: But this is not very helpful. There's no context as to what
Matt: I'm swiping to, unless I swipe to the right $0, $350. Oh, and even then it's not even telling me.
Matt: budget deeper. Slider, 15%
Matt: which I would expect it to speak. $0, 300 entertainment budget, seeper $0 food. Okay, budget seat, $0, total expenses.
Matt: Add expense button. Let's add an expense and see if this is any better. So I'm gonna add an expense this way.
Matt: Trust me. So.
Matt: okay, add new transaction. New transaction for grocery
Matt: product category detected. Icon down image animation of a green screen description, accuracy, medium, okay, drop down list groceries. Alright. So we'll do groceries first, enter info in a box.
Matt: Characters enter 0 10. Enter in funk. enter info. If this is the dollar amount
Matt: it would be nice to be aware of this. Enter box
Matt: showing Braille keyboard. English braille, United States American edition.
Matt: Okay, so  I'm and unclear. If this is  a monthly expense, or
Matt: if this is like a per week thing, so I'm going to assume it is monthly.
Matt: And so I'm going to say
Matt: for groceries this month. I spent 1, 78
Matt: bye. Okay? So I've typed in 1, 75 and going to click next
Matt: one, enter info edit box editing.
Matt: and it brought me to and enter info characters. Enter 3 of 1,175. Enter info in a box editing.
Matt: This is another, enter Info dollar sign
Matt: transactions.
Matt: dollar sign.
Matt: Enter info edit box editing. So that's the dollar amount. But characters enter 3 of 10. I'm not sure what this is for them. 175 edit box. Enter info.
Matt: Yeah, I'm not too sure what this first box is. And there's no context here as to what it is. But let's
Matt: the
Matt: 175. Clearly, if I don't.
Matt: characters enter 3 of 10, enter info in a box.
Matt: So it says, enter info in dollars. Let's try this again. Dollar sign.
Matt: and I'll type in 1 75
Matt: and activate. Done 175 supported
Matt: dollar sign.
Matt: clear text transaction data transaction date 2,024,
Matt: Wednesday, February 20, eighth. okay? And in today's date is the twentieth of February previous month next month.
Matt: and we have a calendar here
Matt: which I'm hoping I can just activate one of the options, and
Matt: it will go through the first of February, 2,024.
Matt: Okay, the second of February the third of February, February 2,024, activate the eighth of February.
Matt: Thursday, February eighth, 2,024 selected, and I got a little vibration, and it says, eighth to February 2024, and both in speech and in braille, it says, selected, this is wonderful, and is nice when these calendars are very accessible. I am quite happy to see this. Normally. These calendars are a bit of a nightmare to use
Matt: the fifteenth of the 20 ninth.
Matt: and I'm going to share it. Up to
Matt: 100 175
Matt: detected 100 characters entered 3
Matt: dollar sign, clear tech transaction data.
Matt: 2,024. Thursday, February eighth previous month.
Matt: But there's no way. Add new transaction
Matt: to confirm it, add new transaction. And there's no error. Message
Matt: 100 clear transact, 2,024,
Matt: the 20 fourth of February, 2,020, the 29. Yeah, it looks like I'm transaction.
Matt: Oh, the 20 ninth of February to add transaction.
Matt: Okay, so it looks like I was a little stuck in the calendar. And now there's an add transaction button.
Matt:  so let's see what happens when I activate it.
Matt: Transaction budget category equals one production equals apostrophe 175, price equals 1, 7, 5, 0 5 8 equals. Thursday, February 8, 13, 5, and 36B s, eastern standard time, 2,024 money manager add expense. Button.
Matt: Okay? So evidently the first edit box is the name of
Matt: the item you bought. and
Matt: so I
Matt: him guessing I would have had to go through
Matt: for grocery wise, either item by item, or
Matt: I just gave the kind of total amount for that Thursday's
Matt: grocery day.
Matt: So what I'm going to do now is I'm going to add another expense.
Matt: And we're gonna go to the drop-down.
Matt: add new transaction window product category detected icon, and we're gonna go to entertainment
Matt: pop-up, window entertainment.
Matt: Excuse me.
Matt: we're gonna add new transactions.
Matt: add new transaction.
Matt: Taking a little bit to engage here. Okay, we've got product category detected. Icon down entertainment box. Okay, enter info. So this should be the name of the
Matt: product. So we're going to add
Matt: in showing Braille keyboard. English braille. United States American edition.
I'm going to type in
Matt: Disney, dot 6 d.
SN.
Matt: It's less great accent
right? Accepting
Matt: no delegates. Dot 3, 4, 6, 7,
Matt: dispenser info. Edit. Box editing. Okay.
Matt: Characters. Enter 6 of 10, Disney. Edit. Box. Enter info
Matt: characters, enter 6 of 10, enter info. This is the dollar amount
Matt: dollars enter info. It's already editing. Don't
Matt: image animation. I'm going to type in $20
Matt: dots 2, 5, 6, and a period, and let's do 95 cents
5. And I delete
Matt: dot 3, 9. Okay, and I'll click done
Matt: simple. 20,495 keyboard hidden dot 20,000. So that actually didn't work as I was expecting
Matt:  And that may be because I'm just typing in braille showing Briokeeper. It does. It was supposed to say
Matt: $20 and 95 cents. I'm going to see if I can fix this.
Matt: That's 4, 6, and that's 4, 6, 7.
You delete. I believe it.
Matt: $20.
Matt: So let's say.
Matt: oops, not type in braille anymore. Oops. that's 3, 4, 5, 0. So let's say, it's $20 and 20 cents
20. Okay?
Matt: And I think we have the same, yeah, with the same results. So what I'm going to do
Matt: is I'm going to
Matt: see if I can. For some reason, not typing in 0 to the decimal point. I'm going to try one more time submitting text
Matt: transaction data.
Matt: clear text, don't resign
Matt: 20.2 0. Okay, 20,435 data books.
24, 2, 0.
Matt: Okay, it
Matt: looks like it did work. So this is no fault of the app. It's just the fault of
Matt: my braille display and a little bit of unsure
Matt: uncertainty of the way to type.
Matt: But that is no fault of the the app. So if you've got $20 and 20 cents, and my Disney plus subscription comes out every fifth
Matt: of the month. So we're gonna go.
Matt: Monday, February fifth, 2,024. Selected. Okay? And I'm going to go to the bottom of the screen.
Matt: The seventh of February the 20 seventh of, because there should be an ad transaction right
Matt: after the last day of the month. the 20 eighth of the 20 ninth of February
Matt: add transaction. Okay, so right, as I got to the 20 ninth of February and swiped to the right the ad transaction button
Matt: took a little bit of time to appear and speak as well. It took about a second or 2. So I'm gonna activate the add transaction button
Matt: transaction budget category equals 2 production equals apostrophe. Disney price equals to 0 point 2 by date equals Monday, February fifth, 1310, and 25,B s Eastern Standard time, 2,024 money manager add expense. Button.
Matt: Okay? So a couple things.
Matt: It would be nice if, because this was a recurrent subscription.
Matt: and maybe we can sort this out in the budget area.
Matt: But at the moment it doesn't appear to be a way to have it tell that it's a recurring
Matt: subscription and also the the way it spoke
Matt: everything was a bit much. It was talking about product label equals and
Matt: amount equals. It would be nice to just say, you know, you have, added Disney, with the amount of $20 and 20 cents to the entertainment category for February fifth
Matt: of 2024.
Matt:  okay. My next part of the task
Matt: is
Matt: I'm going to edit one of the budget categories
Matt: and changed the name or budget. And then I'm going to save it.
Matt: Okay? So we're gonna try this. So let's go all the way to the left side.
Matt: Open navigation, join open up the money manager, manage your budget expenses and control months, expensive budget categories.
Matt: check open navigation drawer budget categories, more options.
Matt: And I actually just realized we didn't add anything into the food category. But that's fine. We're going to change it. To a different name. Category name
Matt: budget cosmies.
Matt: $350. Entertainment.
Matt: $250
Matt: food. Now, if I activate this
Matt: budget category info food, Eddie box perfect.
Matt: That's exactly what I was hoping to happen is that it would have brought up this particular dialogue.
Matt: And I'm going to activate this with the double tap
Matt: food. You cannot change the category name showing Braille keyboard. English Braille, United States American edition. Okay? So I don't know why it won't let me change the category name.
Matt: and it doesn't give a reason why characters enter 250 point clear text. But but if I clear the text
Matt: food edit box editing, and it's category, name category.
Matt: Write the maximum amount, add income rail display input food.
Matt: Yeah, that's very odd. Okay, let's try one more thing.
Matt: Keyboard hidden. Write them a budget. Write the Mac characters, enter food data box category, name budget, category and phone
Matt: food.
Matt: I'm going to do a double tap and hold
Matt: which normally brings up some other items.
Matt: Actions move cursor to beginning. I have actions for talkback move cursor to end, which I have a customer for. Start on and select cancel, and I can't do any editing here.
Matt:  food budget category. Category.
Matt: stop sharing money. Manager goes this way. Let's try the entertainment category 200 entertainment. So I'll activate this
Matt: budget category and phone entertainment
Matt: entertainment. You cannot change the category name. So for some reason, it's not allowing me to change the
Matt: category name, and I'm not sure why. And there's no error, message.
Matt: or explanation as to why
Matt:  so unfortunately, I wasn't able to complete this part of the task.
Matt: But what I can do
keep okay
Matt: is, I will move on to the next
Matt: option, which is to create a budget plan.
Matt: And I'm going to add a deadline for any day in March, which is the next month from today.
Matt: So what I'm going to do is I'm going to go back into the drawer
Matt: budget category and stop share
Matt: budget cap. Evidently I'm not. I need to go back a level. So I'm gonna do a down with left of my phone.
Matt: Okay? So I'm back on the screen, the home screen of the app. And so what I'm going to do now is I'm going to activate the At navigation drawer
Matt: budget, category name or option budget, category, open navigation. money, manager, manager expenses, budget categories, budget analysis.
Matt: monthly expenses, analysis.
Matt: budget plans, budget plans and activate here.
Matt: check open navigation drawer, budget plans, more options. Your wallet contains enough money for this plan.
Matt: Wonderful. Your wallet contains enough money for this plan.
Matt: Your wallet contains enough money for this plan
Matt: soon
on Odeo Grace. Hello!
Matt: To commute a 3, 3, 2, 4, your one.
Matt: Okay. So it just says, your edit. Your wallet contains enough money for this plan. The deadline of this plan has passed.
Matt: The deadline of this plan has passed, but there's no indication as to what detected Icon image. Oh, icon! As to what this is. So I'm guessing it's blank, but the deadline.
Matt: If I click it, it doesn't do anything. Check it, so let me hit. Add
Matt: it, says, plan info
Matt: characters enter plan, title, edit, box, info
Matt: plan, title.
Matt: showing branch. So just call it monthly budget. I guess.
18.
Matt: And I'll activate next.
Matt: But plan description Edgons editing. I'm not quite sure what to type in here. It's not giving me any info as to what I could type. It would be really helpful for those of us who are new to this kind of thing.
Matt: What they can type in here. I'll just type my
Matt: about monthly budget and activate. Next
Matt: Gotcha
Matt: characters entered 17 of 50 plans budget and a box plans, budget plan, deadline date. I have no idea what that is. Plans.
Matt: plans, budget edit box.
Matt: I'm guessing. Characters enter clear text. My monthly budget plans budget. Okay, that's dollar sign. Okay, that's the dollar sign. So I'm going to put 3 50
Matt: for you know. Let's do 800. Once I've done 800. Okay.
Matt: dollar sign. There's no
Matt: real info here. As to what I'm supposed to do. So your text sort of guessing here, plan, deadline date plan, deadline date. So we're going to do march 2,024, Wednesday, February 20 previous, next month, button to activate next month.
Matt: page 1491 of 2,412.
Matt: So it would have been nice if it would have said now, in March
Matt: previous Wednesday, February 20, eighth previous, next month.
Matt: the first of March 2,024.
Matt: So let's choose any day.
Matt: The nineteenth, the twentieth of March 2, tha. Wednesday, March twentieth, 2,024. Selected. Okay. March the twentieth, and we're going to go to the bottom of the screen.
Matt: I plan.
Matt: Go ahead and add our plan. Your plan added successfully. Money manager detected icon, add image icon on a green background. Description medium. Okay, I did get the Ver notification and verification that the plan was added successfully.
Matt: and the final part of the task
Matt: is, we're going to look at the analysis sections.
Matt: So I just wanna check and make sure. This actually went through monthly budget. My monthly budget. Wednesday, March twentieth.
Matt: I'm just wiping the left. The deadline of this plan has passed.
Matt: The deadline of this plan has passed which that is incorrect, because the deadline is March. Your wallet contains enough money for this plan, so I'm a little confused there. But I digress. Let's go into the menu. Your wallet
Matt: budget plans, open navigation
Matt: money back. And we're going to find the analysis.
Matt: Month expense, budget budget analysis. So we have 2. We have the budget analysis monthly expenses, analysis and the expenses. Let's do
Matt: the budget analysis first
Matt: activate open navigation drawer. And here we are. Logic analysis.
Matt: more options. Webview. So this looks like a.
Matt: It's called a Webview, which is a web document
Matt: pie chart, entitled Your Expenses per Category this month, with 2 points. Mean value is 20 Max. Value is 175 article.
Matt: Okay, we've got a data chart here, and I call trial version length. And I caught food
Matt: resonance
Matt: entertainment. So we have my different categories, food
Matt: 0 slash 0 for more information.
Matt: Visit our website, annotation button, which for more information, it's not showing all of my
Matt: expenses. 0 slash 0.
Matt: I wonder if I have to activate each category food. Let's see, entertainment
food
Matt: entertain. So I activated food 0 slash 0 entitled.
Matt: Do it correctly. That's that's a little unfortunate. 5 more options.
Matt: budget analysis, open navigation. Let me check the
Matt: monthly expenses, analysis expenses. budget budget analysis.
Matt: monthly expenses, analysis.
Matt: check open navigation to monthly, more options. Webview. And we have another web document
Matt: citation button web view, and it looks like it's empty, or it looks like it just skips over it.
Matt: Webu window money manager.
Matt: He has a talkback, doesn't read anything here. and it's almost as if it doesn't
Matt: have anything inside. It's an empty web document, because if I swipe to the right it gives me back to my
Matt: zoom. Video controls.
Matt:  overall. I wasn't able to complete a few of the tasks. But the adding experience was decent.
Matt: I think some labeling could be
Matt: helpful, and some descriptions could be really helpful for those of us who aren't familiar the the appropriate info to type in for budgets and and things like that. the the the calendar is great.
Matt: it's it's easy to use. I was able to completely, accessibly activate
Matt: the buttons. Some confirmation would be nice for going to the next previous months. It just said page 1,000 of 2,000 and something which doesn't give me any context.
Matt: and also
Matt: any confirmation messages of of adding
Matt: budgets and and
Matt: it did. It did announce a couple of things, but it could be a bit better if it had some more
Matt: confirmation that things were added
Matt: as well as the unlabeled buttons for the add button and the unlabeled info for these analysis. Especially for this last one here
Matt: of the monthly expenses where it's essentially looks like it's empty.
Matt: and I don't know visually on screen, it's empty. But according to my speech and braille, there's nothing here.
Matt:  But I want to thank you for listening
Matt: to this task today and taking the time to listen to the accessibility review today. So thank you very much for for watching.